[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau bienvenidos a todos a este
programa de radio francia internacional
y de frank sub 24
hoy les hablamos de una de las culturas
más antiguas del mundo algunos de
ustedes a lo mejor la conocen por sus
famosas cabezas colosales se trata de la
civilización precolombina olmeca de la
costa del golfo de méjico y es que a
partir de octubre los olmecas se
instalan por unos meses en el museo de
parís después de haber tenido que
retrasar su viaje por la pandemia del
coronavirus y para hablarnos para
adentrarnos en ese misterioso mundo
olmeca hoy hace escala en parís la
curadora de esta muestra la mexicana
cora falero cora bienvenida y muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros gracias
por la invitación para ustedes asesora
científica del museo nacional de
antropología en méxico también
historiadora y curadora de ésta
la exposición los olmecas cambian el
golfo de méjico por los muelles del sena
por unos meses hasta el mes de julio de
2021 se trata de la exposición estrella
de esta temporada del museo que branly
un museo dedicado al arte y a las
civilizaciones más antiguas de áfrica
asia oceanía y de américa y esta
inauguración estaba prevista en abril
pero por la pandemia del coronavirus se
tuvo que retrasar que ha implicado
porque pienso en esas esculturas tan
monumentales que ha implicado este
retraso en temas logísticos para
trasladar estas obras de arte tan
monumentales bueno pues gracias por la
invitación es un proyecto con una
logística muy un entramado institucional
muy muy complejo porque la cultura mec
ha se caracteriza por estas tallas
monumentales por estas esculturas en
monolitos gigantes que pesan toneladas
entonces bueno ya de por sí eran
un proyecto complicado pero ciertamente
el tema del cob it pues lo complicó aún
más en méxico ahora estamos hay zonas
todavía con semáforo rojo los olmecas
ocuparon la parte sur de veracruz y
norte de tabasco estados que hoy en día
tienen una problemática por covite
entonces el acopio fue un gran esfuerzo
en méxico porque todos los museos
permanecen cerrados y muchos de ellos
abrieron su puerta solo sus puertas
solamente para poder sacar los objetos y
concentrarlos en la ciudad de méxico
proceden de 10 estados del país de 20
instituciones son 300 objetos muchas
toneladas de carga que han llegado a
parís desde el 14 de septiembre pasado
en cinco cargas distintas por el volumen
por el peso que implican y pues sí ha
sido un fuerza un esfuerzo institucional
de parte del instituto nacional de
antropología e historia de méxico
quien combinó con el museo que brand lee
traer este proyecto a francia que es
histórico es una gran oportunidad para
conocer a la cultura más antigua de
méxico o sea que la gente que pueda ir a
esa exposición puede sentirse afortunada
no porque todo lo que lleva detrás de
trabajo sí claro es una yo me atrevería
decir que es una ocasión inédita
por el peso que tienen no solamente el
peso histórico que tienen las
colecciones y no valga forzó enseguida
hablaremos de esas de esas toneladas lo
decían los olmecas y vivieron en lo que
actualmente es el estado de tabasco y
veracruz son 3.000 años de historia se
calcula que el máximo esplendor de esta
civilización fue entre el año 1200 y el
400 de la antigua era antes de cristo yo
me pregunto por qué son menos conocidos
que los aztecas los mayas o bueno en
otros lugares los incas es una pregunta
muy interesante si lo ponemos en la
perspectiva de la historia universal
ciertamente es una cultura muy poca
estuvo muy poco estudiada pero en la
perspectiva de la historia de méxico
pues bueno nosotros tenemos 200 años
apenas de casey de independencia
200 años de comenzar a establecer
cronología sobre nuestro pasado
precolombino es decir antes de que fuera
un virreinato ocupado por españa durante
300 años y bueno esta cultura es la más
antigua se asentó en una zona muy
complicada en una zona
de planicies costeras cercanas al golfo
de méxico pero también es una zona
húmeda pantanosa que está donde pasan
distintos ríos sobre todo el caudaloso
río coatzacoalcos entonces bueno es una
zona compleja para las excavaciones
pues la primera el primer la primera
noticia que se tiene de un vestigio
olmeca es del año de 1853 cuando un
campesino de una hacienda azucarera
encontró la parte superior de una cabeza
la cabeza una cabeza colosal que
conocemos como la cabeza de hueyapan y
pues bueno son muy pocos años
formalmente comenzaron a ser estudiados
apenas el siglo pasado en el en el siglo
20 a principios entonces es una
historiografía muy reciente que apenas
alcanzará en unos pocos años los 100
años y que se ha trabajado de manera
sistémica pero en un período muy corto
todavía hay mucho hay mucho que hacer
cimiento por descubrir sobre descubrió
es claro que si son 300 piezas
básicamente esculturas
hablábamos de esas peculiares cabezas
colosales en la exposición se podrán
mirar por ejemplo la cabeza colosal
número 44 procedente de san lorenzo
tenochtitlan del museo de chala para
cuánto mide y cuánto presa es a la fecha
se han encontrado 17 cabezas colosales
olmecas una de estas 17 que es la más
pequeña pero que pesa cuatro toneladas y
media tiene una altura de 183
centímetros es una de las esculturas
cuyo rostro es muchísimo más simétrico
más estético es un ejemplar bellísimo
que sintetiza muy bien muchos de los
paradigmas estéticos y simbólicos de
esta cultura y justamente es la pieza
que abre la exposición está colocada en
un lugar estratégico para recibir a todo
el público que visite esta exposición a
partir del 9 de octubre en el museo que
branly
el príncipe es el protagonista de la
publicidad diseñada para esta exposición
parisina porque eligen esta pieza para
representar a los olmecas para
presentarlos al público parisino
la exposición está conformada por como
lo decía hace un momento por 300 piezas
procedentes de 20 acervos y de un
resguardo particular hay una pieza en
concreto que viene de una comunidad que
está resguardada por la gente de esa
comunidad
los acervos que participan muy
importantes es el del museo nacional de
antropología que pertenece al instituto
nacional de antropología historia y otro
es el museo de antropología de xalapa
la pieza que seleccionó el museo que
brand lee bueno es una decisión que
obedece a sus necesidades de difusión es
justamente esta que se conoce como 'el
príncipe' es una escultura tallada en
basalto que era una de las piedras más
preciadas y más utilizadas por los
escultores olmecas y sintetiza muy bien
las características estilísticas y
simbólicas que caracterizan a esta
cultura el príncipe es una escultura que
si uno entiende su simetría la postura
que tiene el personaje las
características humanas y felinas que
combina
si uno aprende a observar esta escultura
uno va a entender y va a reconocer
para siempre cuáles son las esculturas
olmecas es decir si tú analizas o si el
visitante que vaya a la exposición
reconoce está carácter estas
características en la forma de su rostro
en el tocado los labios los ojos si no
se le olvidan esas características va a
poder distinguir por siempre cuáles son
las esculturas olmecas tenían una gran
profundidad artística que nos dice en
esas esculturas ese arte sobre la
civilización olmeca su forma de religión
su forma de simbólica de interpretar su
entorno de apropiarse de él con fines
ceremoniales su forma de explicarse ese
entorno con fines religiosos la forma de
contar los días la forma de
de comunicar se sentaron los paradigmas
que prevalecieron durante muchos siglos
en todas las culturas indígenas no solo
de la costa del golfo sino de las otras
cinco regiones son seis las regiones que
identificamos como a mesoamérica esta es
una de ellas y todos estos preceptos
continuaron hasta el momento del
contacto con los españoles 1015 hasta el
año hasta el siglo 16 1521 entonces por
eso es es una cultura muy importante
para nosotros porque entender a los
olmecas es encontrar el significado de
muchos preceptos religiosos urbanos y
urbanos sociales en el resto de las
culturas que forman parte de la
antigüedad de méxico no querría terminar
sin hablar de unas piezas que por
primera vez salen de méxico
usted habla que esta exposición era
inédita y también lo es por eso porque
hay piezas que es la primera vez que
salen al extranjero la primera vez no
solo que salen al extranjero que salen a
europa y bueno que recibe parís que
mejor lugar con la sensibilidad de esta
cultura para entender el arte y todas
sus manifestaciones que mejor lugar que
un museo como el que brownlee
por su fuerte interés por su vocación en
distintas culturas etnográficas
hay esculturas no sólo el mecas sino de
otras culturas que formaron parte de
esta geografía cultural del golfo de
méxico como son los huastecos que ellos
son fueron una cultura posterior a los
olmecas pero que conservaron extra está
tradición escultórica y que la
utilizaron y como siempre pasa la fueron
refinando y hay una gran cantidad de
ejemplares de escultura huasteca que
también el público podrá podrá ver en
esta exposición para entender la
trascendencia de esta tradición
escultórica en la cultura olmeca hay una
pieza que para mí es muy significativa
por las características que engloba
tanto simbólicas como estéticas nosotros
la conocemos como la mujer es calificada
y es el cuerpo de una mujer
en términos simbólicos representa la
fecundidad que representa la naturaleza
la creación pero que en términos
estéticos
no tiene precedentes no tiene
comparación con la estética de otras
esculturas que han sido encontradas en
esos sitios entonces es esta escultura
es la es el objeto con el que finaliza
el recorrido por la exposición que
además es muy interesante porque la
exposición abre con una cabeza colosal
con el monumento 4 de san lorenzo
tenochtitlan veracruz y termina con la
escultura de una mujer para los olmecas
casi todas las esculturas eran
masculinas y entre los huastecos casi
todas eran femeninas
entonces la estética de ambas es
completamente distinta y creo que va
permite un recorrido geográfico y
cronológico por esta tradición
escultórica en el golfo de méxico pues
no nos queda más tiempo muchísimas
gracias escuelas de aero por habernos
adentrado en él
el mundo mágico y misterioso de los
olmecas y recordemos que la exposición
en el que von lee los olmecas y las
culturas del golfo de méxico podrá verse
hasta julio del año que viene si buena
la evolución de la pandemia finalmente
lo permite no claro que sí y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rf y mundo.com y
en france24 punto com hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]